et rob il est caramélisée moi cette
chose que nous puissions voir à qui nous
avons affaire
bon d'accord d'une sucette sir alf l'a15
way et vous vous êtes qui vous êtes le
marchand de sucettes pitié non je suis
assez grand ried vous et melrose un
joueur saumon ces saumons est évident
que du saut bottes mais qu'est ce que tu
fais ici pour écouter votre confiserie à
tous avec un énorme malentendu ok mais
c'est moi sortir de cette brioche je
reprends ma médaille et je vous
débarrasse le parquet ta médaille les
bichons ne gagne pas de médaille eh ben
je suis l'exception à la règle et je
vais gagner en jouant au jeu du héros
sortie certes et on je veux pas tu ne
serais pas en train de nous la jouer
turbo ou quoi non non non non moment
parce que si tu te demandes si tu penses
pouvoir débarquer ici dans mon royaume
et prendre le contrôle d'un enjeu qui
fait sacrément route doucement votre
bouffonnerie